L’histoire de la naissance de Platon est
vraiment incroyable !
Son père, Ariston, s’apprête à « déflorer
» — je préfère utiliser ce verbe sur
YouTube…
Le père de Platon s’apprête à déflorer
la mère, Périctionè — mais là, le dieu
Apollon intervient et l’en empêche !
Donc la mère de Platon ne perd pas sa virginité…
Mais elle tombe quand même enceinte !
Donc Platon naît d’une mère vierge !
Attendez… ça me rappelle quelque chose
cette histoire…
Je pense que vous le savez : Platon est le
géant de la philosophie occidentale.
Bon, d’accord, à égalité avec Aristote
(son plus illustre disciple).
Platon a abordé tous les aspects de la condition
humaine (l’amour, l’art, l’éducation,
la politique, etc.), et il a forgé beaucoup
de grandes idées qui déterminent encore
la manière dont nous, les Occidentaux du
début du XXIe siècle, voyons le monde.
MAIS Platon, c’est un philosophe du Ve siècle
avant J.-C. — donc il y a peu de sources
fiables sur sa vie.
La principale source biographique, ce sont
les Vies et doctrines des philosophes illustres
de Diogène Laërce, qui ont tout de même
été écrites 7 siècles plus tard.
C’est pas l’idéal pour rapporter les
faits.
Il y a beaucoup de légendes concernant la
vie de Platon, mais vous allez voir qu’elles
sont révélatrices — à l’égard du monde
intellectuel de la Grèce antique, mais aussi
du rapport de la production du savoir avec
le fonctionnement de la société en général.
Je vais donc partager avec vous 10 anecdotes
étonnantes et révélatrices sur la vie de
Platon.
Ne manquez pas les dernières : ce sont mes
préférées.
Imaginez que Warren Buffet et Hillary Clinton
aient un enfant…
Autrement dit, la puissance financière et
la puissance politique réunies.
Eh bien, la famille de Platon, c’est un
peu ça.
Platon est donc un ultra privilégié.
Non seulement sa famille est une des plus
riches, sinon LA PLUS RICHE d’Athènes,
mais c’est aussi une famille d’hommes
d’État.
Du côté de la mère, la famille remonte
jusqu’à Solon, qui est souvent considéré
comme l’instaurateur de la démocratie à
Athènes.
Et le père a lui aussi d’illustres ancêtres.
En pratique, il y a toujours quelqu’un de
la famille de Platon au gouvernement.
Et lorsque son père meurt — Platon est
alors tout jeune — sa mère se remarie avec
un ambassadeur réputé.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Eh bien tout d’abord, Platon n’a pas besoin
de travailler.
Donc pas étonnant qu’il critique les sophistes
qui vendent leur savoir, puisque lui n’a
pas besoin d’argent.
Pas étonnant, non plus, qu’il valorise
le monde intellectuel, puisque son confort
matériel est assuré.
Le second enseignement à tirer de l’anecdote,
c’est que Platon est un aristocrate qui
a un sens inné de sa propre valeur.
Il se sent supérieur aux autres hommes, et
il se sent responsable de les mettre sur le
droit chemin.
Vous savez ce que veut dire « Platon » ?
Ça ne veut pas dire « 150 de QI », mais
« large d’épaules » (autrement dit « costaud,
musclé »).
En fait, « Platon » est un surnom — le
vrai nom de Platon est « Aristoclès » le
même que son grand-père).
Il y a plus précisément 2 théories sur
le sens du surnom « Platon ».
La première dit que Platon est vraiment « large
d’épaules ». Ce serait son prof de lutte
qui l’aurait surnommé « Platon » parce
qu’il était naturellement très fort.
D’après la légende, Platon était si fort
qu’il aurait participé aux jeux Olympiques
(il aurait partagé sa tente avec les autres
athlètes, mais sans révéler son identité
[rappelez-vous qu’il est issu de la plus
puissante famille d’Athènes]).
La seconde théorie — qui me paraît moins
crédible — dit que le surnom « Platon
» fait référence à l’ampleur de son
style.
Autrement dit, le surnom signifie qu’il
est capable d’écrire de longues phrases
très travaillées, très littéraires.
Mais comment un champion de lutte, un mec
super baraqué, devient-il la plus immense
star de la philosophie ?
Eh bien Platon s’est longtemps cherché.
Il d’abord a été tenté par le métier
des armes.
Il a fait trois campagnes militaires, et sa
bravoure était reconnue.
Il avait aussi une fibre littéraire et artistique.
Il a composé des poèmes et des tragédies.
Mais il a finalement renoncé à se lancer
dans la littérature.
Mais surtout, étant donné la puissance de
sa famille, il avait un destin tout tracé
: devenir un des dirigeants d’Athènes.
Et il dit lui-même qu’il a effectivement
considéré cette ambition :
« Au temps de ma jeunesse, j’ai effectivement
éprouvé le même sentiment que beaucoup
d’autres jeunes gens.
Aussitôt que je serais devenu mon maître,
m’imaginais-je, je m’occuperais sans plus
tarder des affaires de la cité.
» (Lettre VII)
C’est la rencontre avec Socrate qui change
tout.
Platon a environ 20 ans, et rêve d’une
carrière au théâtre, quand il rencontre
Socrate, qui a lui 60 ans, et qui est déjà
célèbre à Athènes.
Fasciné par le charisme de ce marginal controversé,
Platon prend un tournant.
Il jette ses poèmes au feu pour devenir un
disciple de Socrate.
Quelle est exactement la nature de la relation
entre Socrate et Platon ?
Sont-ils amants ?
Aucun des deux n’en a parlé.
Peut-être qu’à 20 ans, Platon était déjà
trop vieux pour plaire à Socrate…
Il existe 2 versions concernant la vie amoureuse
de Platon.
La première, la version légendaire, fait
de lui un asexuel avant l’heure.
Il aurait été un pur esprit, un modèle
de sagesse, sans aucun désir qui ne puisse
le troubler.
La seconde version, plus réaliste, dit que
Platon serait devenu un célibataire endurci
après avoir été bisexuel.
Parmi ses conquêtes masculines, on connaît
​​le tragédien Agathon, le comédien
Alexis, le rhétoricien Phèdre, et surtout
Dion (pour lequel il a effectué de périlleux
voyages en Sicile [je vous en parle dans une
anecdote suivante]).
Parmi ses conquêtes féminines, il y aurait
la courtisane Archéanasse et, selon certains,
Xanthippe, la femme de Socrate…
Après, Platon préfèrait probablement les
hommes.
Dans Le Banquet, le dialogue où il développe
sa théorie de l’amour, il affirme que l’amour
homosexuel est plus libre que l’amour hétérosexuel
parce qu’il ne comporte pas l’enjeu de
la procréation.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Eh bien, le fait que Platon ne parle pas de
sa propre vie amoureuse montre qu’il veut
incarner sa théorie philosophique, la théorie
des Idées, qui survalorise la vie intellectuelle.
Il soumet son corps, il en domine les impulsions
— il ne se laisse jamais aller.
Une légende raconte par exemple qu’il se
maîtrisait tellement qu’on ne le vit jamais
rire.
Je connais des gens comme ça — c’est
pas forcément une légende.
Vous savez d’où vient la philosophie grecque
?
Les idées ne tombent pas du ciel, elles circulent
avec les hommes.
Et donc une des principales sources de la
philosophie grecque, ce sont les échanges
intellectuels avec l’Égypte.
L’Égypte, c’était à l’époque un
pays mystérieux et fascinant, la plus brillante
civilisation du monde méditerranéen.
Les jeunes Grecs fortunés s’y rendaient
parce qu’ils considéraient ce voyage comme
partie intégrante de leur initiation à la
vie (et puis la traversée ne coûtait pas
grand chose).
C’était aussi une tradition philosophique
de passer en Égypte, précisément dans la
ville sacerdotale d'Héliopolis, pour méditer
sur la mort lors de rituels spéciaux.
Solon, Pythagore, Hérodote, et Démocrite
étaient par exemple passés par là.
Platon, lui, s’y rend après la mort de
Socrate.
Je vous rappelle la chronologie : Platon rencontre
Socrate vers l’âge de 20 ans ; et environ
10 ans plus tard, c’est le fameux procès
de Socrate (qui est condamné à boire un
poison).
Et comme Platon a peur que ça soit son tour
après Socrate, il quitte Athènes.
On ne sait pas grand chose sur ce qu’il
fait en Égypte, mais son séjour a probablement
eu une grande influence sur lui.
Déjà, il vit chez les prêtres du haut clergé,
avec lesquels il peut s’entretenir de théologie.
Et puis certains estiment que c’est l’intérêt
des intellectuels égyptiens pour l’au-delà
qui a inspiré à Platon sa fameuse théorie
des Idées, selon laquelle la réalité matérielle
obéit à des modèles intellectuels qui sont
la réalité ultime.
En tout cas, la ville d’Héliopolis a tout
pour le satisfaire intellectuellement : il
y a des bibliothèques, des érudits, des
historiens, des théologiens capables d’expliquer
le sens ésotérique des mythes, des rites
et des noms divins.
Platon est admiratif du patrimoine culturel
égyptien.
Voici ce qu’il écrit dans Les Lois : « Alors
que chez nous rien ne demeure longtemps des
précieux souvenirs du passé, l’Égypte
inscrit et préserve éternellement dans la
pierre la sagesse des temps anciens.
Les murs des temples sont couverts d’inscriptions,
et les prêtres gardent toujours sous leurs
yeux cet héritage divin.
»
Il n’a pas oublié l’Égypte, et l’Égypte
ne l’oubliera pas non plus.
On raconte qu’autour de l’an 0, des « guides
touristiques » d’Héliopolis montraient
aux voyageurs la chambre où logeait Platon
pendant son séjour, près du grand temple
de Rê.
Vous savez ce qu’est une « académie » ?
C’est une institution dédiée à la culture
et/ou à l’enseignement des lettres, des
sciences ou des arts.
Vous connaissez peut-être l’Académie française,
qui a été créée par Louis XIII pour encadrer
l’évolution de la langue française, ou
encore l’Académie de médecine (française),
qui a pour mission d’éclairer le gouvernement
en matière de santé publique.
L’adjectif « académique » désigne plus
globalement le système d’organisation de
l’enseignement supérieur qui prévaut en
Occident.
Et savez-vous D’OÙ vient le mot « académie
» ?
Il fait référence au jardin d’Akadémos
(un héros de l’histoire d’Athènes).
Platon a acheté ce jardin en -387 pour y
fonder son école, qui s’appelle donc « l’Académie
».
C’est une propriété à 1,5km au nord-ouest
d’Athènes.
Il y a, entre autres, un grand jardin, des
sanctuaires, un gymnase, des salles pour les
cours et pour la vie de la communauté, et
une grande bibliothèque qui comptera jusqu’à
plusieurs milliers de rouleaux (Platon achète
beaucoup de livres rares et chers).
Il donne les premières leçons au gymnase,
puis les leçons plus avancées dans sa maison,
au cœur du jardin.
Il enseigne debout, en marchant sans cesse,
afin de dépenser son énergie physique légendaire.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’enseignement
« à la mode péripatéticienne ».
Cette manière de faire a inspiré un autre
corps de métier…
Que révèle cette anedcote ?
Que l’école de Platon, qui est l’une
des premières universités connues dans l’histoire,
est le modèle originel de l’enseignement
supérieur en Occident.
Et la caractéristique essentielle de ce modèle
originel, c’est que l’élève apprend
sous un angle intellectuel, abstrait — et
non pas par la pratique.
Pour le dire simplement, en Occident, on se
forme dans les livres, avec les idées, comme
les disciples de Platon se formaient dans
son école au début du IVe siècle avant
J.-C.
Une légende raconte que les disciples de
Platon se seraient crevés les yeux pour se
libérer des beautés sensibles et se consacrer
à la pensée pure.
Mais comment ils faisaient pour lire ?
Vous savez qui est l’élève le plus brillant
de l’Académie de Platon ?
C’est Aristote, l’autre géant intellectuel
de l’Antiquité.
Il entre à l’Académie à 17 ans, et il
y restera jusqu’à la mort de Platon (soit
pendant 20 ans).
Je ne vous en dis pas plus sur son passage
à l’Académie, parce que je vais faire
une vidéo sur la vie d’Aristote.
L’anecdote sur laquelle je veux me concentrer
dans cette vidéo, c’est le conflit entre
le maître, Platon, et son plus illustre disciple,
Aristote.
D’un côté, un lien affectif les unit.
Platon a remarqué dès le départ qu’Aristote
est très intelligent.
Il le surnomme « l’intelligence de l’école
» et en fait son principal assistant.
L​​a tradition arabe raconte même que
Platon est tellement attaché à Aristote
qu’il ne commence jamais une leçon en son
absence.
Seulement, ils sont en conflit sur le plan
intellectuel.
Aristote conteste la vision du monde de son
maître, la fameuse théorie des Idées.
Pour Aristote, le sensible sert aussi à trouver
la vérité.
Et puis en philosophie politique, il n’adhère
pas du tout à l’utopie imaginée par Platon
dans La République.
À la fin, le maître aurait été vraiment
déçu par ce qu’il percevait comme de l’ingratitude.
Selon certaines rumeurs, Platon aurait pris
peur qu’Aristote devienne son rival en le
voyant écrire autant ; selon d’autres rumeurs,
c’est Aristote qui aurait tenté un putsch
à l’Académie.
Cette anecdote est importante parce qu’elle
révèle l’origine de la concurrence entre
deux visions du monde majeures dans l’histoire
des idées occidentales, celle de Platon et
celle d’Aristote.
Les penseurs des siècles et millénaires
suivants ne cesseront de revenir à l’une
ou à l’autre vision du monde.
Et c’est tantôt l’un, tantôt l’autre
des deux géants qui prend l’avantage.
Platon ne pouvait pas savoir à quel point
il voyait juste en craignant que son disciple
préféré ne lui fasse de l’ombre.
Platon serait-il devenu un géant de la philosophie
à l’heure d’internet ?
Peut-être pas…
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il se serait peut-être fait prendre…
À son époque, déjà, beaucoup de gens l’accusent
de plagiat.
Il aurait repris les idées mystiques de Pythagore
sans le citer.
Il aurait également repris des passages de
Démocrite, de Parménide, ou encore d’Homère.
Certaines rumeurs circulent sur les méthodes
de Platon.
Selon Aristoxène, un de ses disciples rebelles
(qui sera aussi le disciple d’Aristote),
Platon s’y prendrait de la manière suivante
: il achète l’œuvre intégrale d’un
auteur ; il la consulte ; puis la détruit
(par exemple en la brûlant) afin de pouvoir
s’en approprier les idées.
Il aurait projeté de le faire avec l’œuvre
de Démocrite, mais il a finalement renoncé
parce qu’elle avait déjà trop circulé.
Cette anecdote révèle que la paternité
des idées était déjà un enjeu à l’époque
de Platon.
Peut-être que les autres philosophes étaient
jaloux de son prestige intellectuel ; mais
peut-être qu’il a bien « volé » les
idées des autres.
Et peut-être que, à l’époque comme aujourd’hui,
ce n’est pas sur le véritable créateur
des idées que rejaillit la gloire, mais sur
celui qui réussit à les promouvoir dans
la société.
Avec tout ce que je vous ai dit sur Platon,
vous devez vous imaginer qu’il a passé
sa vie dans le monde des idées — à lire,
à méditer, et à écrire.
Eh bien détrompez-vous : il a essayé de
mettre en pratique ses idées.
Il a été 3 fois conseiller politique à
Syracuse, une colonie grecque du sud-est de
la Sicile.
Il a obtenu cette position grâce à sa célébrité,
mais aussi grâce à sa relation romantique
avec Dion, qui était en quelque sorte le
premier ministre de l’île.
La 1ère fois qu’il se rend à Syracuse,
c’est avant même de créer l’Académie.
Le tyran de l’île, Denys l’Ancien, un
autocrate impitoyable et parano, est alors
l’homme le plus puissant du monde méditerranéen.
Le courant ne passe pas du tout avec Platon
qui, contrairement aux courtisans, se permet
de parler d’égal à égal avec le tyran.
Et puis il le domine physiquement et intellectuellement.
Lors d’une discussion politique, Platon
insulte Denys l’Ancien.
Alors celui-ci se venge en faisant vendre
Platon comme esclave.
Le philosophe s’en sort grâce à un riche
ami qui le rachète (et qui en plus refusera
qu’il le rembourse).
Ça sert d’avoir des amis haut placés !
Mais l’histoire ne s’arrête pas là : Platon
reviendra à Syracuse 20 ans plus tard.
Pourquoi prendre ce risque ? Parce que c’est
désormais le fils, Denys le Jeune, qui gouverne,
et il a un vrai potentiel philosophique.
Platon pense donc que cette fois-ci, il va
réussir à mettre en pratique ses idées
sur l’île.
Seulement, les courtisans disent au tyran
que la venue de Platon vise en fait à aider
Dion (l’amant de Platon) à prendre le pouvoir.
Platon finit donc en résidence surveillée,
et contrairement à ce qu’il imaginait,
le nouveau tyran n’est pas réceptif à
son influence.
On pourrait croire que ces deux échecs suffisent
à Platon — mais « jamais deux sans trois
», comme on dit.
Il se rend à Syracuse une 3ème fois pour
convaincre Denys le Jeune de laisser revenir
Dion, qui avait été chassé entre-temps.
Et encore une fois… ça se passe mal.
Pourtant, le tyran semble vouloir se mettre
sérieusement à la philosophie.
Il a l’ambition d’écrire un traité — mais
Platon se moque de lui : il lui dit sans détour
qu’il n’a pas le niveau.
Platon finit donc de nouveau en résidence
surveillée.
Et il faudra que son ami Archytas, le philosophe
qui dirige la cité de Tarente, envoie un
navire pour le ramener sain et sauf.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
On peut l’appréhender sous différents
angles, mais ce qui en ressort quand même,
c’est l’échec de Platon à mettre en
pratique ses idées.
Passer de la théorie à la pratique, ce n’est
pas si facile.
Surtout quand on a passé sa vie dans la théorie.
Et surtout quand, comme Platon, on n’a pas
l’intelligence psychologique de mettre son
ego de côté pour accomplir son projet.
Vous vous rendez compte, Platon est mort à
81 ans !
Comme Bouddha !
Vous savez ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que Platon est un homme divin…
parce que 9 est un chiffre sacré.
Eh oui : 81, c’est 9 au carré.
On remarque aussi que 8 + 1 égale 9, ou encore
que 9 fois 2 égale 18… et que 1 + 8 égale
9.
Et la valeur sacré du chiffre 9 se retrouve
encore dans la culture.
Par exemple, Hésiode raconte qu’il a fallu
9 jours pour séparer la terre du ciel ; la
guerre de Troie a duré 9 ans ; ou encore,
il y a 9 muses.
La légende raconte que, passionné par le
symbolisme des nombres, Platon aurait tout
fait pour mourir PRÉCISÉMENT à cet âge.
D’autres légendes courent encore sur sa
mort : il se serait éteint en écoutant un
air de flûte joué par une jeune fille ; ou
bien simplement dans son sommeil ; mais selon
d’autres versions, sa fin aurait été au
contraire très pénible, car il aurait souffert
jusqu’au bout d’une maladie de peau causée
par les poux.
Ah oui, c’est pas la même histoire !
Ce que révèle cette anecdote, c’est que
Platon a été divinisé après sa mort (surtout
par ses disciples, probablement).
Comme beaucoup d’autres hommes qui ont une
influence disproportionné dans la culture,
sa gloire a excité l’imagination.
Les gens ont inventé des histoires sur son
compte, ils lui ont attribué des qualités
exceptionnelles, jusqu’à faire de lui un
être divin.
Qui est né d’une mère vierge !
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
que vous avez découvert
des choses intéressantes,
et même inspirantes sur PLATON.
Si c’est le cas,
donnez un pouce bleu à la vidéo,
et puis laissez un commentaire,
pour améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
— ce n’est pas grand chose,
et ça m’aide vraiment.
Vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.
________________
J’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.